وفقا لبيانات موقع مارين ترافيك الذي
يتتبع حركه الملاحه البحريه فان ناقله
النفط باسيفيك زيركون غادرت ميناء سحار في
سلطنه عمان بعد ظهر يوم الاثنين وحددت
ميناء بونس ايرس في الارجنتين وجهه
النهائيه تشغل حامله
ومقرها في سنغافوره وهي شركه مملوكه
للملياردير الاسرائيلي اذن عوفر لما بلغت
السفينه مسافه تبعد 150 ميلا تقريبا عن
ساحل عمان اصيبت بقذيفه الحقت بها اضرار
طفيفه حسب شركه المشغل لها لكن دون احداث
اي تسرب من حمولتها للبحر وكاله بريس
ذكرتنا الهجوم تم بطائره مسيره مفخخه
واكدت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه ان الجيش
الامريكي ابلغ الجيش الاسرائيليه ان
المسيرته كانت ايرانيه من طراز شاهد 136
مسؤول دفاعي امريكي قال للجزيره هجوم كان
بمسيره انتحاريه وان سفينه تتمكنت رغم ذلك
من مواصله الابحار بعد ان قدمت لها
البحريه الامريكيه والبحريه البريطانيه
المساعده واجرتها تقييم للاضرار
هجوم وصفه مسؤولون امنيون اسرائيليون
لصحيفتها ارتز بالخطا الاستراتيجي من جانب
ايران وعلى وقع التوتر بين ايران
والولايات المتحده وقعت هجمات مماثله على
سفنقلات نفط في منطقه بحر عمان خلال
السنوات الاخيره عزيزه المخاوف على البنيه
التحتيه للشحن والطاقه في واحد من اكثر
الممرات البحريه الاسراتيجيه اهميه في
العالم
[موسيقى]